What we mean by valuing our elderly has
probably changed a lot over time.
In traditional societies,
we look to our elderly as the
repositories of our society's history.
It's tradition and it's knowledge.
They were our computer memory banks.
They were the ones who had experienced
and understood all of society's
intricacies.
As time went on,
the elderly were less and less important
for that purpose,
so books first became available and in
books you could write down a scientific
facts,
traditions,
society's history,
and you didn't need the memory of the
elderly as much to remind you of those
things.
And of course when we get to the modern
day,
we seem not to need the elderly for that
at all.
We have enormous repositories of
information in computers and books,
and so we ask ourselves,
what does it mean to value the elderly
today?
And aside from the simple important of
the of elderly being human beings who
have wants and needs and desires and
feelings that we as other human beings
need to respect and help nurture.
And aside from the fact that when we say
the elderly,
we're really talking about our parents
and grandparents and our love for them,
the social question of their function,
whatever that would mean the society may
have changed.
And my suggestion is that though the
elderly may have lost their traditional
role as the repositories of knowledge,
they still have their traditional role
as fonts of wisdom,
their experience,
their lived experience of,
of the decades.
And,
and I'm a great events and social
moments,
uh,
that proceeded.
The birth of the people who could
benefit by them are extraordinarily
important for us to respect.
Because out of that experience comes a
perspective that youth doesn't have.
And so my suggestion is we need to value
our elderly for the wisdom that they can
give us to guide us through some of the
really important decisions that we have
to make in modern society.
Just because my mother or grandmother
May need some help operating her
computer does not mean that she doesn't
have a deeper understanding of how
sitting in front of a computer,
of how interacting with others through a
computer screen
may not be the productive way to,
um,
develop oneself as a human being.
We can draw from our elderly enormous
value through depending on them as a
check and a balance against the excesses
of youth.
And so I think,
um,
that's how we value our,
that's how we should value our elderly.
Uh,
we've changed remarkably in recent times
in our willingness to cater to the
elderly.
We have retirement communities and
activities that we never had before.
But with that tends to do often is to
isolate them from interactions with the
younger generation,
especially in are incredibly mobile
society.
And so I think as a society we do need
to make an effort to mix the general
generation's a little more so that the
younger generations can benefit from the
wisdom of their elders
in bioethics.
The term dignity is bandied about a lot
without people really thinking deeply
about what it means.
No.
Historically,
a French medieval scholar and historian
named Felipe Irys wrote a book about the
stages of death throughout history.
A tamed death is what he called the
first stage in ancient times when people
expected death to come and it was
incorporated into the society.
Then there was a stage called my own
death when people discovered selfhood in
a sense historically individuality,
and for the first time we see grave
markers with individuals' names on them
and there were other phases to the last
phase before.
The one we're in now was called hidden
death where we put death in hospitals.
When we closed the curtain and death was
hidden away from society.
The stage I think we're in now,
I call controlled death.
Today,
our goal is to decide how we're going to
die when we're gonna die under what
circumstances in some cases even
initiating our own death through
physician assisted suicide or
euthanasia.
So what we mean by a dignified death has
changed over time.
And today.
What we tend to mean by it is a death
that I control in my own way where I'm
not stuck in a hospital bed with needles
and tubes going into me under the
control of someone else.
Is that really what we want a dignified
death to be?
That is what society is deciding right
now.
That's what the debate about physician
assisted suicide are about right now.
What does it mean to have a dignified
death?
Does that mean just a death where others
treat you with deference or does it mean
to death where you get to decide the
nature,
timing and circumstances of your own
death?
Researchers are making enormous strides
and brain computer interfaces and there
are two major kinds.
One is called augmented cognition,
and that involves
creating computers that can actually
interact with human beings.
We have very limited memories.
Attention desertion.
When we try to make decisions when we're
piloting a plane or when we're working
on a complex task,
our brains can only incorporate finite
amounts of information.
The idea of augmented cognition is to
supplement that for a computer to be
able to see how a human being is acting
and then reacting to that human being's
needs.
So I don't think there's a major issue
with augmented cognition,
but the second piece of BCIS or brain
computer interfaces is what we call
neuroprosthetics and that involves
actually using computers to supplement,
um,
damage into the function of the brain
and they were actually talking about in
many cases,
implanting computer chips into the brain
or creating an interface,
a physical hard wired interface between
the brain and a computer through
implanting electrodes that are connected
to a computer and that can be used to
help paraplegic and paraplegics and
quadriplegics and manipulate their
environment.
It can be used for or they hope it will
be able to be used for people who have
lesions or tumors in the brain that
disrupt function.
Then we're talking about for the first
time in history,
having brains and information technology
working together in an integrated way.
The good news about that is that brain
plasticity allows that and we may find
that these neural prosthetics helped
people in profound ways.
An example of that would be cochlear
implants.
The problem is once you begin to
supplement the natural function of our
brains with artificially created
information technologies,
you,
you're risking a whole host of problems
from competition between the two forms
of information to malfunction of the
information technology to kind of deep
psychological,
um,
difficulty in understanding that my own
thought processes are no longer only
mine,
but involve some sort of,
of silicon chip that has now been fully
integrated into me because after all,
unlike genetics,
even though we spend a lot of time
thinking about that,
we think of our brains as uniquely us.
My identical twin can share my genetics,
but my brain is mine.
And when we,
when we begin to manipulate the brain,
whether it's through bcis or
pharmaceuticals or in any way,
we are beginning to alter in some sense
that which we think of as most uniquely
ourselves.
And we have to do it with great caution.
Brain imaging research is advancing at a
startling pace for a long time.
I kept predicting that this research was
going to hit a wall and stop and it
hasn't.
So I've stopped thinking that there's a
natural boundary to this research.
What they are doing now is
having people think of objects,
uh,
intentions and and other normal
functions of the brain and through brain
imaging,
they are able to predict what that
person is thinking of what sometimes
with startling accuracy,
certainly if you have someone think of
one object rather than another,
a hammer or a chair.
Brain imaging can now after getting a
baseline predict with great accuracy
which one you're thinking of.
There's research that showed a out of
Berlin that if you asked someone to add
or subtract two numbers together and you
brain image them,
walk once they've decided,
but before they've revealed it to you,
you can predict with great accuracy
which one they have done,
which one they've decided to do.
So what we have now is the possibility
that brain imaging will at some point be
able to actually get fairly detailed and
robust
the predictions or recognitions of what
a person is thinking of.
Now,
this has profound implications for
forensics.
Courtrooms would love this kind of
ability.
They are working very hard on a brain
imaging lie detector and there are now
two companies that actually offer brain
imaging lie detection to the public.
Um,
the question of putting someone in a
scanner to try to determine guilt or
innocence or to try to decide if they
were at the scene of a crime.
They are also using eeg besides brain
imaging for that,
um,
has become a very controversial issue in
illegal channels.
And I don't think that there really is
any consensus about how this can and
should be used.
But even outside of the courtroom,
there are some very interesting
implications of this.
I have two teenage daughters.
If I come home one day and my car is
dented and both of them said they didn't
do it,
will I be able to drag them off to a one
of these new lie detection companies and
say,
get in the scanner.
I want to know which one of you dented
the car.
Would schools be able to use that for
drug searches?
Will companies be able to use that?
We all saw minority report when Tom
Cruise walks into the store and they
scanners in the store and know who he
is,
what he likes to buy,
what he bought the last time he was
there.
There really is a a privacy issue here
that we as a society are going to have
to make a decision about.
One quick example that I think will
illustrate how different this is.
Similar issues that came before.
According to our constitution,
I have a right against self
incrimination.
What that means legally though is not I
have a right to deny you my DNA.
If a court orders it or,
or a hair sample,
the court can take those from me even
though they may incriminate me because
the constitution gives us a right
against,
uh,
the fifth amendment actually against
testimonial self-incrimination.
You can't force me to testify against
myself,
which includes pointing at something
gesturing.
Any action that I do that involves
revealing my thought to you is
considered testimonial.
Well,
what if you could read my brain and get
a piece of evidence that could be used
against me?
Is that testimonial evidence?
Well,
I haven't testified.
Or is that more like blood,
semen,
DNA,
which they can take from me even though
I don't want them to.
The answer is it's not like either of
those things.
It's a new ability that we have as human
beings and at some point the courts are
going to have to decide,
is brain imaging of protected a kind of
testimonial evidence or is it a picture
on a scanner that should be considered
the same way we consider other physical
evidence that I don't have a right to
withhold.
That's one example of the thorny kinds
of questions that this technology is
going to bring.
The stem cell debate has been a
fascinating debate in our society for a
number of reasons.
For example,
we always thought that the abortion
debate was pretty set.
There was a group pro choice group,
pro life,
and it was very easy to determine which
groups were in which camp.
Then stem cells came along,
which are really based on the same moral
objection that an embryo should be
treated as a human being and that human
being should not be destroyed.
But what you saw for the first time was
people crossing camps.
So you had a number of,
of,
of people in Congress,
Orrin Hatch,
and Strom Thurmond and others who are
very strongly in the anti abortion camp
who were also very strongly in the pro
stem cell camp.
Uh,
you had some religious groups that were
against abortion when the fetus was in a
woman's uterus.
But who said a cell in a dish is not the
same thing.
So you had important a schisms there in
this endless abortion debate that we've
been having for over 30 years in this
society,
and that is actually a hopeful thing.
It shows that perhaps by breaking
through some of those traditional
barriers,
we can begin to talk more about
compromise not only on stem cells,
but also on abortion.
However,
the bottom line on the stem cell debate
is unlike the abortion debate,
it is going to go away and it's going to
go away because science is in the
process of,
and there's some successes in this
already being able to create stem cells
without having destroy,
destroy the embryos.
And since the destruction of the embryos
was really the only objection,
uh,
against stem cell research,
one science masters,
the ability to create stem cells that do
everything embryonic stem cells do
without destroying embryos.
Uh,
the debate that debate will go away
assuming that science achieves that
they're very close.
They haven't quite gotten there yet.
Ethics involved scholars from across the
intellectual spectrum,
so philosophers and social scientists.
And then in bioethics you have
clinicians,
you have lawyers and nurses,
and you've got economists and you've got
political activists.
Ethics involves people who approach it
from a scholarly perspective,
those who approach project from a very
sort of pragmatic,
social perspective.
So what ethics really is,
is a conversation and to point to a few
things that are somehow innovative and
ethics is to ask the question of what's
innovative in our society that has
ethical implications.
So for example,
there's a lot of ethical discussion
right now about the proper use of the
web,
twitter,
facebook,
and other kinds of information
technologies and the question of whether
that should be government control.
Should there be regulation there?
Should it be controlled by the people.
There are ethical questions around our
economy.
Of course,
the big one we're dealing with as we
tape this is healthcare reform.
And there are some very innovative kinds
of suggestions that have been made by
ethicists and others about how we might
get around the roadblocks of healthcare
reform.
And in fact,
uh,
the president's bioethics commissions,
both President Clinton and president
bushes have worked hard on these kinds
of issues.
One of the things that interests me of
course,
is biotechnologies and there we have
some fascinating issues and questions
about how we are going to change
ourselves.
A human enhancement has become a very
big
question for those of us thinking about
how is technology going to alter the
nature of being human,
what it's going to mean for our
abilities?
How are our children as they go through
school best,
um,
uh,
considered with attention enhancing
drugs available now with memory
enhancing drugs coming out soon.
Is it a boon to our children or is it
somehow diminishing their developmental
capabilities to give them drugs that
will enhance their capabilities in
school?
Uh,
we now have abilities to predict the
onset,
for example,
of mental illness in ways we haven't
before.
Some work being done here at emory has
suggested that even in children as young
as elementary school,
we might be able to see some beginning
signs of susceptibility to
schizophrenia.
And then the big ethical question is
what do we do about it?
Do we give them a kind of prophylactic
psychiatric medication?
All the medications for schizophrenia?
While they are very important for people
who have it are not nice medications and
you don't want to give them to children,
especially without being able to say,
this child will definitely become
mentally ill,
so what we have now is an explosion in
biotechnology.
We are able to manipulate the plasms and
the functions of the body in a way that
just a few years ago,
we're almost inconceivable and we have
to ask ourselves,
should we do it?
How should we do it and under what
circumstances?
And that by the way,
is where the question of wisdom versus
knowledge actually comes in because the
answers to these questions don't involve
gathering more facts.
They involve thinking deeply about those
things that are of most importance to us
and deciding how we can sustain and
maintain those things even as we use
biotechnology for its best purpose.